hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
you'll notice this beautiful new
addition to my desk
yes it's so pretty i'm so excited to
talk about it today i'm going to be
talking to you about my new monitor and
yes as the title suggests it's something
that i didn't think that i would want or
need but now that i'm using it i'm like
dang
i've been missing out this is this is a
good freaking monitor so yes we're gonna
be talking about my monitor today i've
talked about my desk setup in numerous
different points throughout the year
because it just keeps evolving
including things like my keyboard my
desk met and now this gorgeous new thing
thank you so much to lg for working with
me on this video they gifted me this
lovely monitor and i've used it for
about a week and so today we're gonna
dive in and tell you what i like and
don't like about it okay so first let's
start off with the specs so that you all
know what we're working with here this
is the 34 inch 21x9 ultra wide qhd ips
display from lg it's got an ergonomic
stand which is one of the main features
of this monitor specifically so yes this
is my very first ultra wide monitor and
that's one of the first things i want to
talk about how has it been when you go
using an ultra wide monitor because
wasn't your thing like using a 27 inch
monitor which yes using a 27-inch
monitor was indeed my thing like that's
the thing i've been using for like six
years been through many different brands
but like 27 inch was like a perfect size
for me and so even before setting this
one up i just had one single 27 inch
monitor that was using i use this
monitor setup for writing and editing
and coding and checking emails and
watching youtube but also running xcode
and running premiere pro so like i do
everything from the gamut of just like
some light internet browsing to heavy
pinteresting to some really kind of like
resource intensive very space
intensive stuff that requires a lot of
multitasking a lot of windows open kind
of thing but yeah the tldr basically is
that i love this thing wow how have i
not used ultra wide form factors up
until this point because oh baby have i
been missing out because let me tell you
i think for a long time i was kind of
this like the more monitors the better
the more monitors you have the more
badass you look at work the more
monitors you have the more productive
that you're probably gonna be and uh and
then i realized about like six months
ago that that wasn't the case and i was
just like okay let's let's do some
digital minimalism let's just go with
one monitor because you can't like focus
on more than one app at a time so why
have multiple monitors open so i was
pretty happy with that i did a lot of
multitasking on that one 27-inch monitor
i will say it got me more focused
because i couldn't have multiple apps
open at the same time but sometimes it
just didn't feel like enough space i
will say but i was like willing to live
with it sort of
and then lg sent me this monitor and i
was like you know what doesn't hurt to
try let's just see what the fuss is all
about and uh yeah
it's great i like it specifically
because it's still one monitor there you
don't have like a split in the middle
because of two monitors and so you can
have apps across all the different parts
of the screen and yes it like most of
the time i have more than one app open
in one kind of screen but it does allow
me to have multiple apps open at the
same time which a lot of my work
requires the use of more than one app
because i'm like looking at my notes
from notion and writing them to another
page on notion or i'm looking at one
page on notion and then i'm like putting
it into premiere pro or i'm looking at
something on brave and then taking notes
in notion i use notion a lot and so it's
really nice to just have like just so
much space to have that it's like having
three three windows open on a monitor is
the equivalent of having two
uh windows open on a 27 inch so yeah
there's a lot of space for stuff which
is really nice so yes form factor wise i
will rate this monitor a 10 out of 10
stars misubi's
wonderful little smiley faces i don't
know it's i
i like it i really like it i also like
that it's not too wide um i think the
thing that prevented me from using an
ultra web monitor to begin with was i
didn't like how curved it can be because
i don't like the feeling of being
swallowed by my technology and swallowed
by my screen but this one has a really
nice gentle curve to it that allows you
to see all four corners of the screen
really clearly but uh it's it's like it
still doesn't feel like i'm just being
swallowed whole you know the next thing
that i want to talk about with regards
to this monitor and what i like about it
is the swivel stand i learned about this
monitor because i watched a video from
jossie who reviewed this very monitor
and i was like that stand looks really
clean and really useful and so that's
one of the reasons why i was really
interested in testing this out basically
this stand allows you to move your
monitor in every direction which is so
nice doesn't even come with like a
monitor like a traditional monitor stand
it comes with this like desk mount thing
like most other monitors you have to buy
this separately i used to have like a
monitor
stand that i would attach two of my
monitors to onto my desk but this one
just comes with it and wow it's really
easy to move things flexibly it feels
like it's just gonna
work and i feel like it's not very like
wobbly or shaky or janky or anything
like that and i will say most of the
time yes my monitor is in this position
so there's not a whole lot of swivelly
action but modest is a standing desk
also i like moving my desk to different
parts of my room to work and stuff and
so when that happens like making sure
that i can change my monitor position
really easily no matter where i'm at or
how i want to use my desk just makes it
super easy like i don't have to climb
behind my desk and like unscrew stuff
and loosen screws and tighten screws i
used to have to do that and it was a
pain in the butt there's actually one
very specific use case that i like using
the swivel stand sometimes i set up my
camera right there or like i want to set
it up right here but the monitor is in
the way so literally i'll just move it
and then it's not in the way and i can
still see my monitor for notes and i can
still look at the camera and the camera
it doesn't have the monitor in view so
yes the ergostand offers an expanded
ergonomic adjustment of extend retract
swivel height and tilt as well as
providing a perfect position of the
screen for a more comfortable and
sustainable user experience
because yes ergonomics is important when
you sit at your desk for so long every
single day like i feel it in my
shoulders if it's not the right position
and so having my tools kind of like move
and shift around me so that i
don't like
hurt
pretty important stuff so the next
feature that i want to talk about that i
really like about this monitor is this
whole kind of like plug-in capability i
don't actually know if like this is
super unique to this one but i will say
this is something that i like about this
one basically it has usb ports on the
back and so as long as you connect your
computer to this monitor using the usbc
port you'll be able to connect
peripherals to the monitor which then
will be able to connect to the computer
through that usbc cable which is game
changing because the freaking macbook
pro only has like four ports so it's
kind of important there's like most of
the time when i have like an external
monitor and periphery devices i use all
four ports but literally with this setup
i only have to plug in one
so i have my webcam
and my speakers and my keyboard plugged
into the monitor and then because the
monitor is also charging literally i
just plug in that usbc into my macbook
and i can use all of those things and it
charges i can't tell you how excited i
was when i figured out that's like how
it worked because i was just like
i don't have to use dongles on goggles
on dongles like
oh that's so nice
especially because i i don't know i just
like having a minimal setup and i don't
want cords everywhere so the core
management was also just super easy for
this oh and speaking of cord management
that's another plus of this monitor it's
got really excellent gourd management i
gotta say so all the cords that come out
from the back of the monitor you can
actually kind of like guide it down the
whole ergonomic stand which comes with
like a cover so you can really just hide
away all of your cords and so i don't
have to see any of the cords that are
plugged into my monitor even though i
have a bunch and yeah you know most
monitors come with some sort of cord
management these days but i was just
really happy that this was like super
built in and i didn't have to use like
super dinky looking like cord management
ties and stuff and like invent my own
solution like no it was built in as part
of the monitor so yes this monitor has a
lot going for it it's got really great
swivel stand the form factor is great
the cord management is great the only
con that i can think of for this monitor
which to me is not really that big of a
deal breaker is that the color looks a
little faded compared to even something
like the macbook pro screen it just
looks like the colors a bit white or
like like white washed kind of faded
sort of looking i try to mess with the
different uh settings on it and stuff
but it doesn't really help and so
compared to other monitors out there out
of the box uh with some basic settings
and stuff without doing anything super
fancy
the color is fine which for me like i'm
either coding or writing or if i am
color grading like that kind of makes a
difference uh but not so much that i'm
just like
i don't have a sense of what my color
image is supposed to look like at all
like it's fine but i i think it could be
a little bit better so if you're someone
who needs like super vivid colors and
stuff you know maybe assess that about
this monitor but i i mean for like
everyday use where you're not doing like
really intense color grading stuff where
you need the colors to be super true and
super vivid
not a huge deal so all in all this
monitor really surprised me i really
like it and
uh for the price i think it's something
that i would buy if a company was gonna
buy it for me like if i worked at a
company and then they were like what do
you want for your desk setup i would
definitely choose this one would i pay
that money myself
i'm not really sure i'm just not someone
who wants to invest that much like money
into my desk setup honestly but if you
are someone who wants to i think this is
well worth it so yeah i'm just generally
very surprised by how much i like this
thing using it for the last week i'm
kind of just like how did i ever not use
this like i can't believe i wrote off
ultra wide monitors to begin with
so
yeah just it's it's the whole package
everything is great about it really
there's that only one issue that i would
change and you know that's not such a
big deal for me so i would absolutely
absolutely recommend this monitor thank
you so much to lg for partnering with me
on this video and sending me this
monitor if you'd like to find out more
about the monitor then i'll leave a link
in the description box down below so
yeah hope you like my review of this
monitor let me know what you think in
the comments down below also if you own
this monitor let me know what you think
about it don't forget to subscribe to my
channel for more you know setup review
kind of stuff like this as well as other
tech career in life videos hope y'all
are having a great day and i'll see you
next time bye